bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons tout de suite le sommaire de
cette émission le mois de juin à
versailles sera consacrée au théâtre
populaire à l'occasion du mois molière
les espaces urbains vont accueillir 3
120 représentations nous en parlons avec
notre invité dans quelques instants
lundi 26 mai partout en france ont
célébré la fête de l'est ce temple à
elancourt l'atelier de gravure de
lavilledieu ouvrait ses portes
découverte de ce lieu d'expression de la
musique pour les jeunes pour les parents
aussi pascal parisot sera sur la scène
du scarabée le 3 juin nicolas gervais
nous fait découvrir l'artiste et son
album bête en stock alors dans quelques
instants nous parlerons du molière avec
notre invité johan turbé de l'offre qui
est directeur des affaires culturelles
pour la ville de versailles mais pour
l'heure on part à voisins le bretonneux
où le petit atelier d'art de techniques
artistiques organisées sur deux week end
un stage de raku alors qu'est ce que
c'est que le raku et bien retour sur
cette technique ancienne de poterie
japonaise
qui a mis tout et est peintre et
sculpteur c'est l'accueil à l'atelier
patata débutants et potiers amateurs à
l'occasion d'un stage de raku une
technique ancienne de cuisson de
poteries japonaise utilisés autrefois
lors de la cérémonie du thé on
émaillaient épuisé son vol avant de
l'utiliser de nos jours cette technique
est pratiquée pour la réalisation de
diverses poterie et sculpture
ça permet d'obtenir des couleurs
flamboyantes et des effets particuliers
pour n'obtiendrez peut-être pas de façon
aussi éclatante avec d'autres techniques
de céramique des effets particuliers
c'est bien là toute la spécificité du
raku après avoir sculpté sa pièce puis
l'avoir cuite au cours d'une première
cuisson pour former ce qu'on appelle le
biscuit la poterie est introduite dans
un four à pain
puis tu as plus de 900 degrés la poterie
est sorti directement du four provoquant
un choc thermique qui laisse apparaître
des craquelures caractéristiques puis la
pièce est plongée dans un récipient
contenant un matériaux combustibles
comme l'assurent qui est ici utilisée
pour la poste et y met immédiatement on
a le le lit de ses murs qui va
s'enflammer et qui va créer une grande
fumée noire est cette fumée on va la
capture et en refermant la boîte dans
laquelle on a fait ça
le noir de fumée va pénétrer mais en
profondeur au coeur de la assez
profondément dans la terre dans ce
quelque chose qui pourra pas être lavé
par exemple après et bien sûr puisque
notre émail à craquer de partout
le seul endroit où ces noirs de fumée
peut aller c'est aux endroits où il ya
les craquelures si bien que le dessin
des craquelures va être accentuée par
cet enfumage noir c'est ce petit réseau
qu'on trouve esthétique dans le rack ou
qu'on provoque avec le choc thermique et
qu'on souligne avec l'enfumage une
technique singulière qui permet
d'obtenir des résultats variant l'infini
ce qui donne à la pièce réaliser un
caractère unique ce qui me plaît c'est
quand vous découvrez ce que vous avez
mis que ce n'est pas du tout ce que vous
espériez et c'est autre chose mais
quelques fois beaucoup plus beau
pendant 30 jours à versailles 3 120
représentations seront données dans 65
lieux de spectacles des lieux
prestigieux comme le théâtre montansier
ou encore les grandes et petites écuries
du château ou encore les places parcs et
jardins de la ville nous parlons ce soir
du mois molière avec le directeur des
affaires culturelles de la ville de
versailles pour soir yoann sur medal of
mine bonsoir alors c'est la 19e édition
des actes est-ce que vous pouvez nous
rappeler les objectifs grands objectifs
festival or les objectifs qui sont les
mêmes depuis le début comment françois
de mazières a créé ce festival en 96
c'était avant tout de rendre le théâtre
accessible à tous et de rappeler
le théâtre est loin d'être un art
élitiste est loin d'être un art réservé
uniquement à ceux qui peuvent le
comprendre ceux qui ont un certain
bagage
particulier intellectuelle culturelle
mais que le théâtre c'est avant tout le
reflet de la vie quotidienne le reflet
de la société c'est aussi la défense de
grands textes mais de grands textes ils
peuvent parler à tous de partout et en
fait c'est exactement ça c'est à dire
que son objectif c'était que le théâtre
puisse être dans les instants du
quotidien donc puisse être dans toute la
ville donc aussi bien dans des lieux
prestigieux vous en avez parlé que dans
des petits lieux dans sur les places
dans les sur les dans les rues etc et de
rappeler voilà comme figée que c'est
avant tout un art du quotidien qui peut
s'adresser à tout le monde quel que soit
notre âge quel que soit notre catégorie
socio professionnelle quel que soit
notre provenance familiale ou
géographique voilà ces objectifs là on
les réaffirme de manière un peu plus
forte chaque année alors cette année le
mois molière cette année un festival qui
donne accès comme vous l'avez dit oh à
tous les publics à la fois avec une
programmation professionnelle et par
ailleurs vous mettez en lumière aussi la
vie culturelle locale des compagnies
d'amateurs
alors justement comment vous comment
vous faites cette programmation quels
sont vos critères artistiques pourquoi
vous choisissez un spectacle celui ci
plutôt qu'un autre alors en fait vous
l'avez bien dit à deux types de
programmation au sein du mois molière la
programmation officielle ou
professionnels qui essentiellement
tournée vers le théâtre et là on a un
critère on a plusieurs critères qui en
fait il faut que les compagnies qu'on
sélectionne correspondent à ce qu'on
entend par théâtre populaire théâtre
populaire sous toutes ses formes mais
nos critères ces deux axes soit des
compagnies on ne défend pas
particulièrement le théâtre de stars le
vedettariat on défend avant tout une
énergie collective
vraiment un esprit de troupe exactement
et ensuite que cette troupe que ce
travail ce travail artistique ce travail
culturel soit tourné vers le public on
n'est pas là pour défendre une création
uniquement centré vers ceux qui font la
création tourner vers ceux qui font la
création mais vraiment tourné vers le
public en dialogue avec le public et ça
peut prendre plein de formes différentes
seconde plein de de manière artistique
esthétique différente mais ce sont
vraiment nos critères ensuite on essaie
que tout le mois durant 30 jours ce qui
est long pour un festival est là aussi
voilà je vois sans la représentation
c'était vraiment un des objectifs
initiaux du mois molière que ce festival
dure longtemps
on essaye que tout au long de ce mois il
y ait une représentation de la diversité
culturelle de tout ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui on en parlera tout à l'heure
je pense mais la programmation voilà on
s'attelle à ce que le mois soit
extrêmement représentative de toute la
diversité artistique aujourd'hui donc ça
c'est la partie professionnelle que la
ville offre vraiment à la population
locale et nationale sur laquelle on
s'engage effectivement c'est une
programmation qui défend souvent de
grands textes qu'ils soient classiques
ou contemporains et une programmation
qui essentiellement en accès libre ça il
faut le rappeler si c'était vraiment des
engagements très forts du départ donc là
c'est la programmation de la ville
professionnelle et qui est offerte à
tous ensuite vous avez vous l'avais dit
la programmation amateurs et là on n'est
pas sur un objectif sur une critères
artistiques
on est sur un critère locale le but
c'est de montrer de manière très ouverte
tout ce que versailles produits de
manière amateur dans les ensembles de
théâtre de musique de danse tous que
versailles produit pendant l'année et
montrer au mois molière et les gens
peuvent venir et à différents tarifs
différentes possibilités d'accessibilité
et là c'est vraiment une illustration
ces cinq exactement c'est vraiment une
illustration est là le critère et
géographique avant d'être
d'être artistique et c'est un peu ce qui
constitue notre offre finalement alors
cette année 21 une création vous
proposer la plupart d'ailleurs vont
rejoindre le festival off de vigne un
complexe et encore c'est un gage de
qualité quels sont les temps forts de
cette programmation on peut pas tout
citer donc les temps forts on ne peut
pas tout citer mais effectivement on a
quand même des temps forts qui sont par
exemple les week-ends aux grandes
écuries sont les plus grandes créations
on va avoir rohmer avec l'odyssée on va
avoir un auteur contemporain qui
s'appelle mouret schisgal on va avoir du
feydeau on va avoir du molière
évidemment donc il faut viser vous
retrouvez toute la programmation en
ligne sur mois molière points comme vous
on va vite vous visez les week-ends aux
grandes écuries on commence par la
commune à del arte pur et dur par
exemple ce week-end avec teatro comico
la compagnie qui vient du sud vous
parliez effectivement d'un cycle comedia
del arte je vous propose d'écouter carlo
boso qui est le directeur de l'académie
internationale des arts du spectacle
installé donc a versé à versailles
depuis deux ans voilà depuis 2011 je
crois
voilà qui participent notamment donc à
l'air à la résidence artistique aussi 2
octobre de ce site et donc il nous
présente justement ce qu'elle
est c'est terrible ça veut dire qu'il ya
des personnages populaires qu'il faut
mais les procès aurait carnaval c'est
l'occasion aussi de donner la parole au
peuple ça veut dire des petits gens t il
avait par devers
eux et la commedia saint pée
l'institutionnalisation avec tout ça ça
veut dire est que cette forme de théâtre
entre guillemets politique car elle ça
permet de dénoncer les vices et pour
faire triompher la vertu à la peine tous
à cet effet par des types ça veut dire
est que les comédiens ils avaient
individus et d'équipés représentatives
des différentes catégories sociales et
sociales existent
université le capitaine était
représentée l'armée la
fois au début pardo un peu idiot puis
après au fil des siècles qui devenu un
peu moins bête est plutôt rusé café 10 à
fait tout à fait ça et pantalon noir et
chaussée les démarches à c'était la
mondialisation du commerce
c'est des petits pépins
pendant tout le monde voilà c'était
comme un théâtre très populaire mais
d'un contest est populaire dans des
places dans des lits qu'ils n'étaient
pas des billes au t1
alors pour finir est-ce que vous pouvez
vous donner un exemple de spectacle à ne
pas manquer pour les familles alors pour
les familles c'est très simple par
exemple tous les mardis soirs vous
pouvez aller aux grandes écuries pour
voir du molière parce que finalement les
classiques voilà les classiques vous
pouvez aller au chapiteau de
porchefontaine pour voir notre cycle
nouveau cirque par quelle manière c'est
aussi exactement à qu'une de nos
résidences artistiques au chapiteau
méli-mélo donc phare du cirque au
chapiteau de porchefontaine tout le long
du mois et pour les plus petits par
exemple pouvait voir des comptes au
théâtre montansier parce que le théâtre
montansier redevient des grands lieux de
création du mois molière et donc qui
ouvre les mercredis du mois molière avec
les comptes des cons qui sont venus un
peu de partout venus d'ailleurs donc
voilà ça plutôt pour les plus petits
très bien merci beaucoup
rendez vous donc à versailles tout le
mois de juin retrouvez la programmation
complète sur le site internet merci
merci lundi 26 mai partout en france ont
célébré la fête de l'estampé le public
était invité à découvrir les différents
événements organisés dans toutes les
régions et à elancourt l'atelier de
gravure de lavilledieu vrai ses portes
découverte de ce lieu d'expression
depuis cinq ans yannick duby nos
enseignes les différentes techniques de
gravure au sein de l'atelier d'arts
graphiques de lavilledieu le cours de
ces lundi est exceptionnellement ouvert
au public à l'occasion de la fête de
l'estampé une célébration nationale qui
fait référence à lady de
saint-jean-de-luz du 26 mai 16 160 qui a
reconnu au graveur le droit d'exercer
leur librement au xvème siècle les
tempêtes un procédé de reproduction
d'image au fil du temps elle devient un
moyen d'expression majeur pour réaliser
des oeuvres d'art part entière j'ai à
coeur de que l'on considère la gravure
comme un art majeur enfin majeur au même
titre que la sculpture et la peinture et
c'est en passe de le devenir parce que
nous devons nous sommes de plus en plus
nombreux à y croire et à développer non
seulement les techniques traditionnelles
qui existent mais leur ont aussi leur
adjoindre des tas de découverte les
graveurs sont des gens curieux sont des
gens qui espère aimant beaucoup et qui
cherche à tout prix à
se surpasser aussi quelque part on se
surpasse alors ça but ça peut être par
les formats pour certains ça peut être
par pour eux sur des différents supports
pour d'autres une estampe et l'empreinte
réalisés à l'encré sur un support souple
plaques de bois ou de métal gravé pour
obtenir une matrice d'impression il
s'agit donc d'une image imprimée sur
papier qui peut exister en plusieurs
exemplaires à l'atelier de gravure les
artistes viennent parfaire leurs
connaissances et leurs pratiques
je crois que ceci c'est un dieu de
de liberté un espace de liberté
d'expression l'expression pure c'est à
dire que moi je suis la polytechnique et
uniquement pour la technique je ne vais
pas du tout inquiétés sur leur domaine
la création c'est que je respecte
profondément à pratiquement tous cas
tout ce qu'ils recherchent et je suis là
pour les aider
catherine azoulay villiers est un tri
sculpteur depuis plus de dix ans elle a
rejoint l'atelier cette année j'avais
choisi de travailler seul chez moi j'ai
une presse mais au bout d'un moment donc
si on vit de partage et de s'enrichir de
aussi d'autres expériences d'apprendre
d'autres techniques ici j'ai découvert
le travail sur le bois pour moi c'est un
mélange de sculptures et des travaux
quelque part parce qu'entre on entend le
bois c'est son dessin sur les bois avec
des outils spéciaux on en en taille on
retire le bo du bois on en retire par le
cros mais c'est pas le creux qui sera
ancrée c'est la surface
un stage pour débutants et
approfondissement de pratique pour
d'autres est organisé les 21 et 22 juin
de la musique pour le jeune public pour
les parents aussi pascal parisot sera
sur la scène du scarabée à la verrière
le 3 juin et nicolas gervais nous fait
découvrir l'artiste et son album bête en
stock pas bête ce chanteur pour parents
à chercher la petite bête pour séduire
les enfants dans un spectacle jeune
public qui s'adresse à toute la famille
et qui sera présenté notamment le 3 juin
au scarabée voici pascal parisot dans le
kiosque
j'ai découvert un truc complètement
dingue comme avait toujours caché jusque
là j'ai découvert que vous et moi on est
des bêtes et ça je ne savais pas on elle
est belle
on est des bêtes
c'est pas moi qui se content and he man
et décidé de faire des disques pour pour
les enfants c'est milan jeunesse coeur
d'éditeurs de vivre assez connu et un
jour la directrice artistique
m'a appelé elle connaissait mes chansons
pour pour les grands je voulais dire ça
maintenant et elle trouvait que c'était
très facilement déclinable pour pour les
petits
y aura plus de bambi à la carte
mais d'autres pans à la moutarde
départ dans ma tête je me suis dit n'ont
jamais fait j'y arriverai pas bref je me
suis essayé j'ai fait deux trois
chansons je lui ai envoyé elle m'a
répondu tout de suite elle m'a dit
écoute aux personnes écrit comme ça pour
les enfants ou aujourd'hui c'est super
on adore c'est parti voilà et donc j'ai
fait un premier premier disque qui
s'appelait les pieds en plat chez milan
jeunesse suivi de béton stock suivi de
la vie de château c'est moins volé un
bonnet un japonais par contre ça ne s'en
va la violette
il a rosi la salle odette
ça ne se lave pas très souvent
inconnus impôts des siècles baisse à 105
sans quoi
là j'ai pris des animaux mais à la
limite c'est un prétexte un
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de chansons qui
parlent absolument pas d'animal 1 les
thèmes sont sont très très très très
vaste puisqu'il ya même une chanson sur
l'eau sur sur le poids des sacs d'école
on n'est plus dans une thématique animal
c'est un prétexte cette thématique est
un prétexte pour pour écrire les
chansons qui c'est qui va chercher là
dedans
sous les oreillers des enfants
qui la remplace par le dieu sont
avec une incroyable adresse guy
c'est la petite souris
la petite souris
j'ai pas de message à faire passer aux
enfants je
remplis mon rôle d'artiste décrivent
heures de faiseur de chansons d'après
ces petits se débrouille avec un fait
pareil pour les grands je fais je fais
pas de cas avec ça il se trouve que j'ai
de la chance parce qu'ils aiment bien il
aime bien les chansons donc tant mieux
mais moi je pense pas une espèce de j'ai
pas ce côté
éducateur
à la maison
d'un animal pour compagnon
il m'a refusé tout ce qui bouge même
malheureux poisson rouge donc j'ai pas
de challenge et pas de chien j'essaie de
faire des chansons intelligente
avec des mots qui vont peut-être pas
forcément toujours comprendre mais c'est
pas grave s'il y en a deux trois
parlement jeudi plateforme pétrolière
bon ben ils vont demander à leurs
parents ce que c'est depuis leur tendre
vont leur expliquer c'est un mot qui va
rester a gravé à jamais dans leurs oeufs
dans leur mémoire ça c'est sûr je sais
pas de me dire ça y est j'ai 6 ans n'ont
fait ridicule j'écris les chansons pour
les enfants comme j'écris des chansons
pour pour leurs parents des fois et avec
la même rigueur
j'espère que ça son tour mais
aujourd'hui ça va beaucoup mieux j'ai
trouvé un
méchant
les parents qui ont des disques pour les
grands et qui emmènent leurs enfants
le disque quand ils écoutaient mes
chansons pour les grands leurs enfants
aimaient et que maintenant qu'ils
achètent mes chansons pour les petits
donc pour leurs enfants eux aiment aussi
ces chansons-là donc comme les albums
pour les adultes j'ai choisi un
instrumentarium je décide un peu du son
que j'ai envie d'avoir en gros on est
quasiment un groupe même si c'est moi
qui joue tous les instruments s'il peut
arriver ce qui n'est pas le cas en
général je travaille avec jacques mon
percussionniste jacques tellitocci
mais par contre on joue tous les deux
tous les instruments mais comme s'il y
avait un groupe circle moi je dis je me
dis tiens il y aura un piano acoustique
droit il y aura une contrebasse il y
aura une guitare acoustique nylon un
ukulélé et une petite batterie de
cuisine casseroles grosse caisse puis
voilà et on s'arrête à ça tout ça c'est
important pour limiter de l'album et
pour le son c'est aussi
quelque part éduqué je disais je faisais
pas dans l'éducation mais les enfants à
entendre des sons d'albums de chanter
des reprises qu'il ne t'embête se
précise
ça donne un spectacle et déjà on ait été
beaucoup joué on est trois sur scène
donc il ya une batterie
qui est mis batterie mes batteries de
cuisine comme je disais à l'instant avec
des casseroles il ya un un bassiste
s'appelle pascal colomb et je suis à la
guitare et on chante les chansons de de
béton stocks dans un décor forestier en
me dire
voilà après les petites bêtes de pascal
parisot on retrouve une autre
journaliste palette qui fait rugir de
plaisir les spectateurs du kiosque au
regard
merci nicolas découvre honda présent les
vos sorties ciné au micro d' elodie
moines moi j'ai bien aimé je pense que
c'est un film pour les filles aussi
apprécié j'ai passé un très bon moment
et j'ai bien aimé mais je pense je
pensais je pensais pas que ça allait
être un film comme ça que ça va être
beaucoup plus guère qu'une fois que
c'est un film très triste vas-y sur les
sentiments
j'ai bien j'ai bien aimé a vraiment
c'est un très très beau film c'est très
réussi à tout point de vue que ce soit
de l'histoire par elle-même les les
décors les personnages c'est vraiment un
monde féerique et et le fait que ça a
été sa revisite les contes moi ça m'a
beaucoup plu c'est un très bon film j'ai
bien aimé sur un film de disney ça
raconte vers l'histoire qui s'est passé
c'est un magnifique conte revisité par
les américains mais c'était très joli
j'avoue que je pense que ça plaira aux
enfants angelina jolie joue à la
perfection il ya un côté féerique à côté
je pense que c'est un film qui est
autant pour les petits que pour les
grands chemins très très passionnant
c'était historique que c'était beaucoup
de dimension
c'était très pros dont un très beau film
plein d'émotions justement la vo a
permis d'avoir
de saisir pleinement fait la différence
entre deux cultures et de langues entre
les personnages certains films séries
fox et peut être de l'humour auquel on
n'est pas très habitués mais c'est
vraiment drôle
cette semaine c gueye pino responsable
du grenier à sel à trappes qui nous
livre son coup de coeur
notre coup de coeur de la semaine au
cinéma le grenier à sel c'est le film
last days of summer le dernier film
réalisé par jason reitman des indes
reitman c'était le réalisateur de juno
et in the year et nous retrouvons dans
les rôles principaux kate winslet et
josh brolin kate winslet pour faire un
petit poêle qu'athènes s'était titanic
et charlesbourg l'insee près les goonies
ils ont fait d'autres choses entre temps
évidemment mais les plus ce qui les a
rendus célèbres c'était ça le l'histoire
du film c'est un
un homme qui
entre guillemets kidnappe une femme et
son enfant il va s'incruster chez eux et
il est poursuivi par la folie est blessé
et
il fallait garder un peu prisonnier chez
eux et en fait me parler une relation
qui va se créer entre jeunes rolinek et
riesling qui est qui à s'étendre ça se
passe pendant les derniers jours de
l'été c'est un beau film qui dure 1h40
et que nous proposions en version
originale vous retrouverez évidemment
tout ça sur notre site internet cinéma
grenier à sel point com
allez je vous propose à présent deux
autres idées de sorties ces prochains
jours tout d'abord l'espace de covile à
voisins bretons ne va résonner au son du
métal alternatif samedi de 15h à 1h du
matin deux scènes extérieures
accueilleront 12 groupes enfin samedi et
dimanche vous pourrez assister aux fêtes
médiévales de neauphle-le-château au
programme un tournoi interne
international de joutes équestres un
marché médiéval et de nombreuses
animations pour toute la famille notre
émission est à présent terminé merci de
l'avoir suivi sur tv fier je vous
retrouve donc la semaine prochaine en
direct à 18h30 à mercredi